uh brett favre talked about this
yesterday too and
the the one thing he communicated with
aaron rodgers the one thing that stuck
out to me
rogers told far i'll touch base with you
when this is all over
which serves as further confirmation
that there's something there's a lot of
crap going on yeah
that that will be over at some point not
i don't hey brett don't believe
everything you read
on the internet brett it's all fake it's
all phony it's no big deal
i'll touch base with you when this is
all over that tells us everything that
we need to know
one one more point though yeah that uh
was raised yesterday by rob demotsky of
espn
and and it was it was one of those
little things that was tucked into a
longer column
that just you look at you say oh wow the
packers believe
that the 49ers and the broncos have
tampered with aaron rodgers
they're not going to do anything about
it because they know how hard it is to
prove tampering and even if you can
prove it
it's hard to get the nfl to do anything
about it it's such an arbitrary
decision that the nfl makes the last
time they hit anyone with tampering was
the chiefs with jeremy macklin because
they talked directly to him not to his
agent during the window when they were
allowed to talk to his agent stupid
and everyone does it uh but uh
chris i i it really it's it's jarring to
see it in writing but when you think
about it well yeah at some point
dave dunn probably called the 49ers and
the broncos and if they do anything
other than hang up the phone immediately
when he starts talking about aaron
rodgers it is tampering yeah that's
where i want to just go like
i mean yeah it's tampering but like
you know i don't know a coach who
wouldn't they all take tampering serious
to a degree to like how you explained it
like direct contact with a player or
anything like that
i mean that's a no-no coaches don't do
that
you know and and i have a hard time
thinking that
any move or trying to reach out
to rogers just in my experience being
around it with my dad
my own career following the business now
like i haven't had a hard time thinking
the broncos or the 49ers
were the ones to reach out to start any
type of conversation
no way my history around the nfl in this
type of situation would be the exact
opposite
tampering was done by the player and
what is the nfl to do about that that's
it's like you said like you know hey
aaron's interested in your team
what this is tampering hang up like come
on that's not realistic
like that's that's not going to happen
that's not that's not that's the sausage
is made in the nfl
that's that's what drives me crazy about
the tampering rule right because
that is required i remember a few years
ago adrian peterson called jerry jones
or so he was on the phone he ended up on
the phone with jerry jones he started
talking about how much they like to play
for the cowboys and jones engaged him in
the conversation
right in reality what jones should have
done was immediately end it and contact
ziggy wolf the owner of the vikings and
say hey your player called me up and
started talking to me about playing here
you need to know about this that's what
the rule requires but that's not how the
rule is enforced and
chris i wrote about this last night at
pft on one hand
i see the benefit in filing tampering
charges because
it could maybe back teams off it's the
warning shot at
everyone don't mess with our guy on the
other hand
two points one everybody tampers so
you're gonna set yourself up for
tampering charges if you start making
them yeah
and two two does it really matter at
this point
you know tampering becomes a problem
when it puts ideas in a guy's head
that maybe he decides at the end of the
day i'd like to leave you're already at
the point where the guy says
i'd like to leave he's shouting it
without really saying it
so it's not like there can be any more
damage done to the relationship the
relationship is already fractured
possibly beyond repair but nothing any
team does
at this point to try to convince aaron
rodgers to play for them is going to
make a difference
no exactly right yeah and you know again
i mean i just don't know there's no rule
what's the rule for
getting a player in trouble for
tambourine because that's there is none
i know how to that's right
that's what's weird that's what's weird
exactly right yeah
you know the best example is this when
you go to a veteran player who's due to
make five million dollars this year and
again you say we only want to pay you
two million we need your decision
tomorrow
the agent's job at that point is to call
every other team
and basically find out what else is out
there right
and if it's more than two million
somewhere between two and five maybe it
gets lucky and it's more than five
but that's what you're expected to do as
the agent but any team that engages in
that conversation
has engaged in tampering right but it
happens
all the time it happens before free
agency it happens with veteran players
who are facing
pay cut ultimatums it happens all the
time that's why
it would be unfortunate for the packers
to do it they did it in 2008 with the
vikings
with brett favre but again these are
things that aren't initiated by the team
they're initiated by the players agent
and i firmly believe it happened here
yeah but i also believe the league would
never do anything about it and it's not
going to matter
there's no reason to try to scare anyone
away
everybody already knows where this thing
stands yeah you're right the only
question is where it goes from here
yeah and who knows i don't know where
where it goes from here
i really don't i'm i i guess what
right now if you had to make if i had to
make a guess
i feel like the trade's not going to
happen
rogers is going to come back for one
year he's going to be the one that
bends and says screw it and he's going
to make it known that this is his last
year in green bay that's what
that's what i'm going to bet on i'm
thinking i don't think he's willing
enough to get dirty to make a trade
happen now and say no
i think he's going to come back and
he'll get it out through the channels
that listen they i'm a little lame duck
thing
they're they they're not supporting me
and he's gonna basically make it clear
that this will be his last year with the
green bay packers that's that's what i'm
gonna say now
why would he blow it up in the
off-season if he was willing to come
back for another year
why would he do that he i mean i think
you know like you always said
i you know i i don't know but i think he
tried to do it
quietly and not blow it up for a long
time and gave them
you know some red flares shot in the air
to be like hey warning
one month left warning two months left
like i i'm i'm i
you got to do something i'm not happy
and i think he just must have gotten to
the point where he felt like he had to
blow it up here to to get some movement
or get the conversation going the way he
wanted i remember back during that
two-day window after he spoke following
the loss to the tampa bay buccaneers and
that set off the firestorm up holy crap
he may not be back
and i had reported that it was a
contractual issue
that he wanted to have the security
right he was going to be the guy for
multiple years
he goes on pat mcafee's show and it's oh
we have these conversations all the time
oh it's no big deal
bull crap no what yes
and again as we've said from time to
time and we'll continue to say
believe no one believe nothing and our
function
is to tell you what's really going on
when the folks involved say what they
have to say
as they try to win the pr side of it
there's
always something deeper that is lurking
that
is far closer to the truth the truth for
the 49ers is
they did make a phone call about aaron
rodgers i think it was more than just
kyle shanahan calling matt laflore and
matt laflore saying you're wasting your
time
regardless they ended up with trey lance
they have jimmy garoppolo
the owner of the team talked about the
plan
moving forward hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports